alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment dites-vous mère
d'accord alors comment dites-vous maire
et comment dites-vous grand-mère
d'accord alors comment dites-vous voir
alors comment diriez-vous mère du maire
et grand-mère dans la mer
le français n'est pas ça  dur
tu veux te détendre
là tu vas c'est
mon mec
qui sont mes parents célèbres
d'accord c'est très intéressant
regarde oh mon dieu j'ai pris tout ton tu es
chauve maintenant oh non
tu es audacieux
[Musique]
oh mon dieu mika tu es chauve
j'ai pris tout ton regard de peluches oh c'est
ta fleur
alors je viens de finir le concert sur le
panthéon
qui est une sorte de temple des
droits de l'homme et de la république de france
beaucoup de philosophes sont enterrés ici
beaucoup d'
écrivains
et  j'ai fait un concert et puis nous avons grimpé
jusqu'aux meilleurs